[Music]
foreign
we have a busy news night for you coming
up we're going to bring you the very
latest from Biden's border crisis and
crime crisis things are more out of
control than ever it's shocking and all
of it preventable also swimmer Riley
Gaines will be here she was just
attacked again trans activists even
spitting at her during a ceremonial Bill
signing in Texas but first I think we
right here on this show we did hit a
nerve at the Biden White House
apparently they were watching this
program last night by the way thank you
all for watching at the White House and
we're triggered by this interview with
the speaker of the house Kevin McCarthy
when you move to an impeachment inquiry
it empowers Congress Republicans and
Democrats within their subpoena to be
able to get the answers they need
because we have found time and again we
haven't seen anything like this since
the Nixon Administration using their
government to shut down any time we had
a question I would think the Biden
family would want to clear their name
first I really am it's it means a lot to
me that the Biden White House is
watching this show but they are clearly
terrified of what is a very real
impeachment inquiry and Joe Biden's
White House is now lashing out and
accusing speaker McCarthy for what he
said on the show of actually lying whoa
considering Joe's the biggest liar that
gets interesting now wait until they
hear the breaking news I'm going to give
the White House a preview of Coming
Attractions you want to tune in tomorrow
night and the night after there's going
to be a lot of news and a lengthy
statement from White House counsel their
spokesperson Ian Sims well that probably
took him all night to write Sims is
complaining that McCarthy is lying about
three specific things now here's the
first alleged lie quote McCarthy told
Hannity a bite Administration has
obstructed house Republican
investigations this is the monsterably
false well that's very odd since the
Republicans leading the investigations
they've both been on this program James
Comer Jim Jordan they say that is
demonstrably true and it started right
after the GOP won their majority in the
house last year and according to
Politico quote the Biden White House
launched their first major broadside in
response to incoming House Republicans
quote the Biden administration had no
immediate plans to respond to a slew of
Records requests instead the White House
demanded that Republicans start from
scratch in 2023 that does not seem very
Cooperative that's certainly not
transparent to me but the obstruction it
didn't stop there according to the house
oversight committee chairman James Comer
well the Biden Treasury Department
refused to turn over the suspicious
activity reports that they requested
those were racked up by the Biden family
Syndicate unless of course the Democrat
signed on to the request which in itself
was a highly unusual request and while
Biden's Treasury Department ultimately
had the cave they were still falling for
as long as possible and of course
Biden's FBI also as you know if you
watch this program attempted to obstruct
and stall important house oversight you
may remember after House Republicans
asked the FBI to produce that 1023 form
documenting bribery allegations against
Joe and Hunter Biden from a trusted and
well-paid in the past FBI Source the FBI
first refused to even confirm its very
existence then director Ray well he
defied a legally binding subpoena and
refused to produce even a redacted
version of the document it was only
produced after the Republicans had to
push it this far and were on the verge
of holding the FBI director Chris rake
in contempt and we'll have more on this
1023 form in a moment now sadly
roadblocks were employed and are
employed anytime a republican has
requested information on the bidens but
apparently that is news to Biden
spokesman person Ian Sims who basically
lied himself today or is completely
ignorant so is the unusual 3.5 million
dollar payment from the Russian oligarch
to Hunter Biden Now Sims claims that
speaker McCarthy that his claim had been
debunked by The Washington Post wow now
contrary to what Mr Sims would have you
believe Hunter Biden did receive 3.5
million dollars from the former first
lady and oligarch in Moscow according to
the U.S Senate committee on homeland
security and governmental Affairs and
the U.S Senate committee on finance let
me read from their 2020 report quote
Hunter Biden received a 3.5 million
dollar wire transfer from Alina baterina
the wife of the former mayor of Moscow
the report continues quote on February
14 2014 bot Arena wired 3.5 million to a
Rosemont Seneca Thornton LLC Bank
account for a consultant see agreement
that's Hunter's business anyway Rosemont
Seneca Thornton is the investment firm
co-founded by Hunter Biden on July 31st
of this year Ohana's friend and business
partner Devin Archer confirmed this
payment during testimony on Capitol Hill
and he said he wasn't really sure why
the payment was made and quote it was
not supposed to go in that bank account
but that's where it went and according
to Archer batarina's company invested a
hundred and twenty million more dollars
in their real estate fund and Archer
also testified that a few months later
in the spring of 2014 Hunter and Joe was
Joe at the time vice president and this
Russian oligarch they had a beautiful
dinner together at Cafe Milano in
Washington D.C
Ian do you care to explain this one were
they just talking about the weather or
was this all one big illusion which
brings us back to the FBI 1023 form now
in his length the fact checking
statement while Sims accused speaker
McCarthy on this program last night of
spreading lies about this form and took
issue with McCarthy's claim that the FBI
did not act on the bribery allegations
from its own trusted informant and Sims
claims that this has been thoroughly
debunked by Guess Who The Washington
Post the propaganda outlet for all
things Democratic Socialist Now Sims
wants us to trust that the FBI handle
the allegations appropriately well
apparently in the left's fantasy world
the politicized FBI should never be
scrutinized forget the Russia collusion
hoax forget that the FBI propagated all
that for years and years to get about
Hillary's dirty dossier that they used
to get and secure what not one but four
fisa warrants and uses evidence to
backdoor spy on the Trump campaign and
rude Carter Page's life forget about
fisa abuse and the politically biased
FBI agents that were tired for lying
forget about the FBI's efforts to
pre-bunk Hunter Biden's very real laptop
during weekly meetings that they had
with big Tech even though the FBI had
had possession of that laptop and
verified its authenticity they had the
laptop in December 2019 they knew it was
real by March of 2020 then why were they
meeting with big tech companies in the
weeks leading up to the 2020
presidential election telling them these
big tech companies may be victims of a
misinformation campaign a hack and dump
operation and it might be about Joe and
Hunter Biden and if they love the wapo
fact Checkers so much why didn't Mr Sims
today cite the four pinocchios that they
gave Joe Biden when he actually lied
about money that his family got from
China uh sorry Ian Sims I think we're
done taking the FBI or any Biden at
their word and by the way now you're
included in that category especially
this close to a presidential election so
I have a question or two for Mr Sims now
that I know he's watching now Mr Sims
did candidate and President Joe Biden
will you acknowledge and admit to the
truth that he lied to the country
repeatedly when he said he'd never ever
one time discussed his farm business
deals with hunter or his brother or
anyone else for that matter he lied as
president he lied as a candidate we all
know he lied but if the bidens have
really nothing to hide and want to clear
their good name they should instruct
well the FBI to open up their books and
show us their investigation and of
course that's not going to happen now
they don't want us to follow the money
because as Speaker McCarthy laid out
last night all roads lead to the big guy
himself take a look
if you're an expert when it comes to
foreign policy why isn't it Italy or the
UK or France hiring you why is it just
Ukraine Russia China Romania and why is
the then at the time advocating and
putting your family members on boards
that you want action in why are you
providing these families Porsches why
are you saying you have no no saying in
this business but now we find lo and
behold you've gone to dinners and after
those dinners 3.5 million dollars flows
now noticeably missing from Ian Sim's
statement is a rebuttal to those
allegations hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else